[Music]
she blazed the Beauty on screen and now
Emma Watson is revealing her favorite
beauty secrets now she takes a bath up
to three times a day and she uses fur
oil for the hair that's on her head and
in well other places that's what we love
about Emma she is an open book meanwhile
Emma's co-star Josh GAD and Luke Evans
more like a live musical with a curly
seal there's no man in town happens did
you as it might a smiler ha ha ha ha
everyone's favorite guy everyone's awed
and inspired by you and it's not very
hard to see why ah I love that thank you
you look for any opportunity I had to
sing funerals in projective yeah
christening yeah red commie tea segments
oh yes we are guests there Beauty and
the Beast stars our partners in crime on
and off screen
so is this Hollywood's newest bromance
this man is the only other person I know
that can start finish a sentence with a
song just like myself
yeah we double act you were meant to be
meant to be put together
yeah you guys seems we've been having a
blast on this tour doing a lot of social
media who between the two of you takes
the most pictures I thought I did but I
actually stopped trying to compete I
can't do it anymore
and Luke's guest on even ranks higher
than love foo for Josh's two daughters
Ava and Isabella they broke my heart a
little bit because afterwards I asked
him who their favorite character was in
the movie looking for a quick pick-me-up
and they're like Belle and Belle's daddy
and villager number 4 chickens I love
Gaston I was at like 36 or 37 on the
list
[Music]
you